tell your friends at home that Gino does
deliver so what I like to do is I gel
and then blow dry oh interesting hey
Matt say less fellow young coaches uh
Hey clef where's Kyla uh
see I prefer to play this game because
it's harder to intercept the grenade
[Music]
as hell
football and gaming combined together oh
this is like homework
it's the fighting Brothers game you know
I'm sick of our parents where I have
your jersey and have mine
whatever are we going to do everyone
calm down I coached my homes in college
that's right Brown's you pieces gang
stop kicking me out why are the Brazil
one [ __ ] team to make a cake this
weekend ow please let me out I'll limit
my screen time yeah of course I tried
blowing up see come back man you uh
missed the Chiefs game
[Music]
oh look at my boy Super Bowl Shawnee we
stand a shark King for real for real
rare Seahawks dub xmh TBH brush is kind
of mid so I straight ghosted yo Rashad
Penny hitch different this year she
yo I dead ass do not know what went down
at USC for real for real